على مرمى البصري تمتد حقول زراعات الكبرى
في منطقه قلعه الاندلس بمحافظه اريانا
لونها الاخضر بدا يتحول تدريجيا الى
الاصفر بسبب الجفاف وقله الامطار هذه
زراعه مهدده بالانكسار كما يؤكد كمال
ويحيى الفلاحان بالجهه ليجد نفسه عن انقاذ
زراعتهما
لونها كان معناها تواصلت معناها نقص في
الامطار هذه الزراعه هذه الكلمه توصل
معناها تعطي المنتوج اللي همم
نتاملوا معنا
نتكلم
في وزاره الشباب
الوضع هنا لا يختلف وكثيرا عن باقي مناطق
البلاد حيث يواجه اكثر من نصف مليون فلاح
تونسيه خطر ضياع عصابات هذا العام بسبب
الجفاف
الجفاف هو نقص الامطار يهددان الزرعه
والزرعه في تونس التي بات تحت خط الفقر
المائيه وصار فلاحوها في صراع دون اسلحه
مع وضعيه تاريخيه فعالت معها الاصوات
المناديه بضروره اعلان حاله الطوارئ
المناخيه في البلاد
وتاكد السلطات ان الوضع المائيه كارفي حيث
دخل تونس مرحله الفقر المائيه وتتجه
تدريجيا نحو العطش حيث لا تتجاوز سعه
السدود فيها 25% ولا حل الا في الاستقلال
عن ري المحاصيل وترشيد استعمال الماء في
باقي المجالات
مش بتقول كده بس برشا
ما عدناش خياره اخرى اليوم رشدوا في
المياه
البحر ومحاولته
المائيه وسدودها وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس